Hey YouTubers, this is Charlie
This is going to be my walking dead Episode 15 video.
subheading - Crazy Rick episode
There is so much awesome stuff to get to, so I'll just
- just remind everyone that a new round of the giveaway
starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
Careful for  spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet.
Starting with my top 5 moments
#5 is Nine Inch Walking Dead Nails
Technically, the band is broken up -
but I love the mix that Deanna's family was listening to
- such a great way to open the episode
I think I've mentioned it in previous episodes before but the Walking Dead
- tries to mix things up with the ways they shoot their intros.
Like, sometimes they'll be really cinematic...
Sometimes they'll use really interesting music...
I think my second favorite music episode of The Walking Dead
-- or music intro was the Bob intro from Season 4
Both very sad ways to open the episode
but I felt like the Bob one was a little more melancholy
The Trent Reznor music is just to get you Amped Up
which is why they intercut with Carols oven heating up
The oven of Alexandria is heating up
They also had the Carl and Enid kitchen timer thing too
I just love the way cooking is a metaphor in the finale
Even though Deanna seems super pissed
that she left the casserole on the door step
It still feels like she's coming from a place of sanity
like, she hasn't completely lost it yet
She's a politician so - she knows how it goes
On to #4 Deanna and Rick argue about what to do with Pete.
This is a really good example of balancing forces in the episode
so, like, they don't want you to think that any one character
...is more right than the other.
Rick's perspective is valid
and Deanna's is too
She doesn't want to kill anyone but -
Rick doesn't want to let the abuse continue.
Really the thing that sells it for me is when Rick -
- tells Jesse later that inside here is the same as out there.
it depends on whether or not you believe him when he says that.
and which side you come down on.
- if you agree that the rules of the outside world should..
..be the same as the rules inside Alexandria.
if so, then you're in Ricks camp.
I think that most people will come down on Ricks side.
Letting wounds fester, like Pete being a giant wound
will only cause Alexandria to rot from the inside.
its not going to get better, people will still die no matter what.
whether they die by abuse or Rick's Revolver
On to #3, Sasha goes Crazy.
I don't mean literally crazy, but that she's going a little nuts all over walkers.
Michonne and Rosita went a little nuts too
I think they took the opportunity to let off some steam in the woods.
They want you to think sasha's going nuts-
- but really, she hasn't done anything that doesn't need to be done.
someone needs to take care of all the walkers, so why not her.
She's actually doing them a service.
And even though she took down Rick at the end of the episode
I still think Michonne is going back and forth about the way she wants to live her life.
Like, if she wants to adopt the Alexandria way of life or be the person with the katana
I love that flashback scene. That was the first time in Season one that she appeared.
Or technically that was the season 2 finale.
That's the mode that Sasha is in right now and I feel like Michonne is going to take her katanna off the wall in the finale at some point.
Something really important to remember too, Sasha is hanging up in the tower.
She kinda saw there was a commotion going on with Rick's fight at the end but
she used the opportunity to pick off a bunch of walkers at the wall
Nicholas, the one that had stolen Rick's gun and hidden it in a coffee can - stole it
he heard the gunshots at the wall. They didn't address that, but I'm wondering if Nicholas is going to overlap with Sasha in the tower.
If anyone were going to be the one to take him down, I would want Sasha to be the one to do it.
Moving on to #2. Daryl and Aaron find more signs of the Wolves.
They waited until the end of the episode to explain it, but they've been finding dead walkers all over the place.
Then they found the ones chopped up into bits, then they found the one tied to the tree.
And if it wasn't entirely clear when they said it, she was alive when they tied her to the tree.
meaning that these "Wolves" are sick as shit
If you remember the episode where Tyreese died, there was a sign that read "Wolves not far"
I've said it in previous episodes, but I think that the Wolves are stand ins for the scavengers from the comics.
Just a terrible group in the DC area...not to be confused with Negan and the Saviours. Totally different group.
That doesn't answer the question of where Morgan is. I know that a whole bunch of people were hoping Daryl would run into Morgan.
he could still show up in the finale. There are still a whole bunch of question about Morgans storyline and how
it's going to tie back in with the survivors
So just open up a bookmark in Google Chrome for Wolves and Morgan
And my number one moment, RICK vs. PORCHDICK
I think we were all expecting this to happens so I don't think this is a surprise. It's from the comics
I think the way that they're doing it on the show is just a little bit more drawn out.
But I think its going the way we all expected. Alexandria is Thunder Dome. Two Men Enter, One Man Leaves
All I could think about during the fight was Peter Griffin vs the giant chicken on family guy.
In all seriousness though, they wanted you to question who would win the fight - like - they didn't want it to be a easy win for Rick
He's a big guy and it's gonna take a lot to take him down with his fists.
Normally he'd just shoot him but because he is in that community, Rick was hesitant to draw his gun and fire.
That scene right after he talked to Jesse the first time was him just looking at all the kids and people sitting around
You'd think that he was formulating a plan but honestly I don't think he has much of a plan in his head
He's just like I'm gonna deal with this the way I deal with everything
The problem is that they're in Alexandria and there is a giant group of people living there and people aren't used to his way of doing things.
It was so much fun watching Rick try to explain himself to Jesse - hes so inarticulate, he couldn't come out and say I really care about you
That's his neanderthal way of telling her that he really cares about her
Love in the time of the apocalypse. I haven't heard anything about Jesse surviving to season 6. Hopefully she makes it
I would like to see something happen between them, but first, porch dick has to be removed from the equation.
So here is my question for you guys. How do you think they are going to resolve the Rick vs Porch Dick situation.
It seems like what they are suggesting is that Rick will end up killing Pete but somehow the Wolves storyline will intersect with that
So it wont just be Rick vs Pete. It will be Rick vs Pete in this greater context of the Wolves
And a giant army of walkers that seems to be massing at the gates more and more. It's kinda of like the prison round 2.
Only this time, Ricks group is the invading force.
I've seen a lot of comments from you guys asking if Rick is the villain this time around
Has he turned into Shane or has he turned into the Governor. I don't this that he has but anybody who has
stumbled upon this episode without knowing who Rick was, and watched that scene at the end, they would thing Rick is crazy
like oh my god, what is wrong with this guy.
It isn't untill you have the broader context that you start to sympathize with Rick more.
because look at all the things he's been through
because if they head dealt with the governor the same way, then woodbury probably wouldn't have gone down the same way.
People probably wouldn't have died. Same thing goes for the prison.
If you want to think about the Rick and Shane comparison think about it like this. Shane was much quicker to sacrifice members of the group.
I think Rick still thinks about it like it's still a measure of last resort.
but he wont hesitate when he decides that somebody need to "go"
They've changed a few things from the comics. If you've read them, just use spoiler tags.
It's a little more clear cut in the comic which decision has to be made - like - what Rick has to do
In the circumstances in the show that are keeping Pete alive aren't quite the same in the comics.
He's not quite as necessary to the people of Alexandria as he is in the show.
So, don't forget that next week is the finale. Be sure to subscribe so you get my video.
I'll be doing a double give away and I'll be doing some bonus videos after the fact
I'll still be doing a Q and A but I'll also do some extra bonus videos after the finale
Feel free to leave any of your requests, but now we're into territory where we can talk about season six.
Especially after the finale, we can start speculating on when Negan is going to show up
What's going to happen with the next big group of villains, what they're going to do inside Alexandria once they deal with Porch Dick.
And I know I didn't mention it in my top 5 but we all have to give Carl a giant high five for getting a little play in the woods.
Carl is now one of the most eligible bachelors inside of the safe zone under the age of 18
So while you guys wait for me to post my Walking Dead Q and A tomorrow, you can click HERE for my latest Game of Thrones Season 5 Video
I just uploaded a Daenerys video and you can click here for all my other Walking Dead Season 5 videos
Thank you so much for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow. High Fives!!!